>> Martha: ALL RIGHT, CHAD,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU YOU HERE TONIGH
>> THANK YOU.
>> Martha: REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ, MEMBER
OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH US PAIRED
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
WHAT ARE THE ISSUES THAT ARE
OUTSTANDING THAT ARE TOO FAR
AFIELD IN THE PACKAGE FOR
REPUBLICANS LIKE YOURSELF?
>> WE WOULD ALL AGREE THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS BILL DOES NOT NEED
ANY POISON PILLS.
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS THE
EASY WAY TO SPOT THE ISSUES.
EVERYONE IS FOR TESTING.
EVERYONE IS FOR MEDICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE VENTILATORS.
WHERE REPUBLICANS HAVE
CHALLENGES IS WHERE WE HAVE
LEGISLATIVE PROVISIONS THAT
CHANGE ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS.
WE SHOULD NOT USE THE
CORONAVIRUS AS AN EXCUSE TO GO
AND DRAMATICALLY EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY IN THE STAFF
PROGRAM, FOR EXAMPLE.
SO WE WANT SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
MEDICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FOCUSED,
TESTING FOCUS, BUT DON’T REWRITE
ENTITLEMENTS WHILE WE ARE
DEALING WITH THE CORONAVIRUS.
>> Martha: THAT MAKE SENSE,
CAN YOU PUT PROVISIONS THAT IT
IS A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME, AND
I THINK THAT IF MOST AMERICANS
GET WIND OF THAT THEY WOULD
PROBABLY BE BEHIND THAT?
>> UNFORTUNATELY WE SEE THE
SPEAKER THE HOUSE TRYING TO JAM
THE PRESIDENT.
PUTTING IN FOR EXAMPLE
REFORMATIONS TO ABORTION LAWS
AND ABORTION PRACTICES, THE
HEIDEMAN INTO THIS LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE AS A WAY TO MAKE
REPUBLICANS AND THE PRESIDENT
LOOK LIKE WE DON’T SUPPORT
TESTING.
NOW THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT’S NATIONAL EMERGENCY
DECLARATION HAS UNLOCKED
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL.
FOR EXAMPLE, HERE IN FLORIDA AS
A RESULT OF THAT DECLARATION WE
SPENT $6 MILLION TO BUY
ADDITIONAL VENTILATORS AND PUT
THEM CLOSE TO COMMUNITIES THAT
WILL BE IMPACTED.
>> Martha: I DON’T THINK THAT
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF PATIENTS
IN AMERICA FOR THINGS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE THE ZONE OF WORKING ON
THIS IMMEDIATE PROBLEM.
AND I THINK THAT EVERYBODY WOULD
HOPE THAT BOTH SIDES WOULD AGREE
TO THAT AND THE OTHER THINGS CAN
BE BATTLED OVER AT ANOTHER TIME
AND PLACE.
WITH REGARDS TO YOU, YOU SELF
QUARANTINE FOR HOW MANY DAYS?
AND WHY?
AND WHAT MADE IT OKAY TO STOP?
>> I HELD THE PHONE OF SOMEONE
AT CPAC WHO HAD TESTED POSITIVE
FOR CORONAVIRUS.
I WAS NOTIFIED OF THAT 11 DAYS
AFTER THE EVENT AS I WAS ON
AIR FORCE ONE WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
AS SOON A SIDE AIR FORCE ONE
RIDE WAS OVER I WAS PUT IN A DOD
VEHICLE, TAKEN TO WALTER REED,
TESTED.
THAT TEST RESULT CAME BACK
NEGATIVE.
HEALTH CARE OFFICIAL SAID I
SHOULD MAINTAIN THOUGH
QUARANTINE THAT ENDED AT
2:00 P.M. YESTERDAY, NOT
"STRAIGHT OUTTA COMPTON," BUT
STRAIGHT OUT OF QUARANTINE.
>> Martha: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT?
I WAS JUST A LITTLE BIT
SURPRISED TODAY WATCHING HOW
EVERYBODY WAS STANDING SO CLOSE
TOGETHER AND THEY WERE ALL IN
THE SAME MICROPHONE, ALL PUTTING
THEIR SELVES ALL OVER THE
PODIUM.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
EXPOSURE, OBVIOUSLY, THEY HAVE
ALL INTERACTED WITH A LOT OF
PEOPLE AS YOU HAVE.
DID AT THE PRICING AND TERMS OF
SENDING THE RIGHT MESSAGE TO THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY IN TERMS OF
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND HOW WE
SHOULD BEHAVE?
>> THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS PRETTY REGULAR
HYGIENE THAT HE MAINTAINS USING
THE USE OF HAND SANITIZER.
HE DID THAT REGULARLY BEFORE.
SO I THINK THAT THERE’S A
CERTAIN RESILIENCE WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND THOSE AROUND HIM.
OBVIOUSLY WE WERE ALL ANXIOUS TO
GET THE TEST RESULTS TO BACK
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT HAD WALKED
HIM ALL OVER MAR-A-LAGO WHERE I
WAS IN A NUMBER OF OTHER PEOPLE
WERE.
WE WERE HOPEFUL THAT THE RIGHT
INFORMATION IS OUT THAT THERE
WAS A NEGATIVE RESULT, BECAUSE
SO FAR NO COMMUNITY SPREAD AT
MAR-A-LAGO AND THE EVENT LAST
WEEKEND, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT STAYS THAT WAY.
BUT ALL MY FRIENDS AT THAT PARTY
ARE STILL HEALTHY, A SYMPTOM
ADDICT.
THAT IS GREAT NEWS.
>> Martha: A QUESTION FOR YOU,
IT SAID THAT YOU TOOK PAID SICK
LEAVE WHEN YOU WERE ON YOUR
QUARANTINE, IS THAT TRUE, AND IF
SO, THEY WANT TO KNOW WHY YOU
VOTED AGAINST THAT IN FLORIDA?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I NEVER VOTED
AGAINST PAID SICK LEAVE, I VOTED
TO PREEMPT PAID SICK LEAVE SO
THAT WE DID NOT HAVE 67
VERSIONS.
EACH AND EVERY DAY I HAVE BEEN
HOME I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE GOVERNOR, OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE DIRECTORS AND
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICIALS TO MAKE
SURE THAT MY CONSTITUENTS ARE